Trascrizione: Giulia Toffolon
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Da circa due anni,
per andare al lavoro impiego poco tempo.
Il tragitto è sicuramente più corto,
ma anche la scelta dei vestiti
è molto più semplice:
una maglietta o una felpa,
a seconda del freddo reatino;
e pantaloni rigorosamente lunghi.
Una volta salita in macchina
arrivo al lago di Ripasottile,
che la mattina dorme,
con la sua copertina di nebbia
e l’edificio grande delle idrovore
che fa da guardiano.
Poco più avanti arrivo al mio giardino.
A rompere il silenzio
ci sono otto gatti affamati,
che mi aspettano.
Facciamo colazione insieme
e il sole, quando la mattina,
molto presto, incomincia a salire,
e la luce filtra
tra le particelle sospese,
è un mondo incantato.
Pian pianino, però,
i colori da tenui
diventano sempre più vivi:
Il verde, poi il giallo, il rosso;
e infine i colori molto più cupi,
seguendo la tavolozza delle stagioni.
In piena fioritura quello che faccio,
in genere,
è dedicarmi, all’inizio, alla raccolta.
Quindi vado dove coltivo i fiori eletti,
e raccolgo i fiori,
in questo modo.
Questo momento è molto delicato
per una farmer come me,
perché ci permette di notare da più vicino
i fiori, le necessità delle piante
e se ci sono, ad esempio,
delle invasioni di insetti non previste,
o delle malattie.
Quindi, una volta raccolti i fiori
li colleziono in dei vasi
che poi porto dentro la mia stalla
che è un laboratorio di floral design.
Quindi mi dedico
alla creazione di bouquet,
o allestimenti per eventi.
Ci sono tantissime attività,
come ci sono del resto anche in campo.
Quando finisco la raccolta dei fiori
incomincio a fare i lavori un po’ più duri
che mi garantiscono un’abbronzatura
sempre con la manica stampata
e incomincio a togliere le erbacce,
mettere in sicurezza le piante.
Ci sono tantissime attività,
dalla progettazione del giardino -
quindi porre un seme,
un bulbo o un tubero
e poi il trapianto.
Durante la mia attività, durante l’anno,
seguo da vicino ogni passo
che mi porta a vedere fiorito
il mio giardino.
Vi starete chiedendo che cosa faccio.
Io ho una flower farm.
Esistono davvero tante flower farm
nel mondo.
L’etichetta anglosassone
l’abbiamo recepita in Italia
per indicare delle aziende agricole
che si dedicano alla coltivazione di fiori
in modo stagionale,
quindi non c’è una forzatura dei fiori,
e in pieno campo,
senza l’utilizzo di pesticidi
e seguendo un approccio organico.
C’è una motivazione
un po’ triste da una parte,
ma anche molto felice.
Vorrei girare la medaglia
e mostrarvi quello che c’è
nel resto del mondo
in quello che è
il settore della floricoltura.
Ad esempio, sapete dove avete comprato
i fiori che avete regalato
a una persona che amate?
O quelli che utilizzate
per dire arrivederci a una persona cara?
O quelli che vi hanno portato all’altare
o dal vostro compagno?
I fiori fanno parte
della nostra quotidianità,
perché è bellezza allo stato puro.
Ma nessuno si chiede:
“Da dove vengono quei fiori?”
Oltre il negozio, chi li produce?
Ad esempio, poniamo il caso
di trovarci a febbraio,
quando a San Valentino
si regalano le rose.
Chi ha un giardino saprà
che le rose in quel periodo non esistono.
Non esistono perché fa troppo freddo,
bisogna aspettare maggio.
Le temperature, quando si alzano,
sicuramente aiutano il fiore a sbocciare,
alcune volte anche ripetutamente,
ma in Italia non succede
di certo a febbraio.
Quindi, siccome le stagioni
sono invertite,
a sud dell’Equatore
è proprio il momento ottimale
per coltivare questi fiori.
A sud dell’Equatore
ci sono intere nazioni
dove i produttori si sono spostati
per dedicarsi alla
industrializzazione del fiore.
Esistono delle grandissime serre,
piene di fiori,
solitamente monocoltura,
quindi si specializzano;
e li coltivano sfruttando persone
e purtroppo anche elementi
che danneggiano gravemente
l’ambiente e la salute.
Uno di questi può essere il DDT,
che qui in Italia, e in Europa,
non si può più utilizzare,
ma che lì non è normato.
Le flower farm, in questo senso,
cercano di risolvere
un problema molto grande
proponendo una soluzione
locale, stagionale, come v raccontavo.
Questo ha dei riscontri positivi
sotto vari punti di vista.
Ad esempio, sapreste riconoscere
questo fiore?
Oppure questo, che è lo stesso?
Sono dalie.
O anche...
questo più piccolino,
che nei campi eravamo soliti a vedere
nelle tonalità dell’azzurro.
Le flower farm sono un posto meraviglioso
dove si coltivano fiori
di ogni tipo e di ogni varietà.
Questo tipo di fiore è molto delicato,
e se fosse coltivato al sud dell’equatore
dovrebbe viaggiare per aereo, ibernato,
arrivare in Olanda
e dall’Olanda arrivare nelle grandi città
e dulcis in fundo al negozio e a voi.
È un tempo molto lungo,
mentre il fiore ha una durata brevissima;
rispetto alla verdura,
o alla frutta, deperisce.
E per questo, le flower farm
sono quel posto magico
dove potete trovare meraviglie del genere
che possono essere utilizzate
per voi o per chi volete.
Nella mia flower farm, ad esempio,
quest’anno ho coltivato
più di 300 varietà di fiori diversi;
e la cosa molto buona
è che tornano a fiorire i fiordalisi,
specie che sono estinte
a livello spontaneo
perché non utilizzo pesticidi
né nulla di tutto ciò;
e lo faccio con immenso amore
tutti i giorni da due anni a questa parte.
Fino a due anni fa,
la mia attività era diversa:
sono un ingegnere.
Ho sempre cercato la mia strada,
non sapendo di preciso quale fosse.
Da bambina sognavo di diventare una cuoca,
poi un astronauta e così via.
A un certo punto mi sono ritrovata
a scegliere la carriera da ingegnere,
l’ho portata a termine;
e, proprio quando
effettivamente avevo il modo
di dare il giusto valore a tutto il tempo
che avevo impiegato negli studi
e nella mia quotidianità,
mi sono tirata indietro.
La cosa bella è che non avevo capito
cosa sarei andata a fare.
Poi guardando su Internet ho scoperto
questo bellissimo mondo delle flower farm
e ho detto:
“I fiori potrebbero essere quell’elemento
che mi permette di essere creativa,
di esprimermi in tutti i sensi.”
Perché un fiore ha colore,
profumo, delle forme.
Quelli che coltiviamo nelle flower farm
non sono sempre così dritti
come uno si aspetterebbe
perché il clima influisce
su tutto, anche sulla forma.
Tutto questo mi ha talmente entusiasmato
che ho deciso
di abbandonare la mia carriera
e di intraprendere una strada
che non conoscevo.
Non ho mai avuto il pollice verde,
ho sempre fatto morire
qualsiasi tipo di pianta
ed è assurdo che oggi
ho un giardino pieno di fiori.
Una delle flower farm
che mi ha aperto gli occhi su questo mondo
è Florent, dove ho seguito
anche un corso
perché è molto difficile coltivare fiori
e se non si studia è più una passione.
Poi sicuramente l’esperienza insegna.
Un’esperienza per cui
durante l’anno bisogna aspettare.
Se si sbaglia, l’anno prossimo
forse si risolverà il problema o forse no.
Forse il fiore non è adatto
a questo luogo.
Insomma, ci sono tantissimi aspetti.
La mia strada si può dire
che è stata segnata, sicuramente,
dalla presenza dei miei nonni
che si sono sempre dedicati alla natura,
da mia nonna,
che tuttora, come metro di misura,
utilizza l’orto o le galline
per dire se sta bene.
Quindi se va nell’orto sta benissimo,
altrimenti qualche problemino c’è,
però a 94 anni è comprensibile.
Anche mio padre, appena può,
sfugge sul trattore
e io sono sempre rimasta un po’ in bilico,
non sapevo cosa fare
e siccome ero portata
dal desiderio di riavvicinarmi alla natura
ho compiuto un passo enorme.
Perché comunque ci vuole coraggio
per abbandonare determinate certezze
e incamminarsi su una strada dove
assolutamente non conoscevo nulla.
Nonostante tutto, oggi sono qui
a parlarvi di questo
sperando che anche voi, un giorno,
scegliate dei fiori sicuramente locali
ponendo l’attenzione su tutto il processo
e su tutto quello che c’è dietro.
Non c’è bisogno di mangiare qualcosa
per rendersi conto che si può fare meglio
e si aiutano anche tante realtà sofferenti
per determinate situazioni
e anche la terra.
Vorrei concludere con una frase
di Beth Chatto, una giardiniera inglese
che, in un posto dove il clima
per i giardinieri è perfetto,
ha studiato affinché riuscisse
a costruire un giardino roccioso
con piante che non richiedono
grandi risorse idriche.
E lo ha fatto perché ogni pianta,
secondo questa giardiniera,
deve essere coltivata nello spazio
che gli appartiene,
non deve essere forzato.
E come io alla fine sono diventata
una pianta che è ritornata a casa,
il lago si trova veramente vicino a me,
così, in modo spontaneo,
senza sentirmi fuori luogo,
ma parte integrante
dell’ambiente che sto costruendo.
Auguro anche a voi di essere piante forti
che affondano le radici
in un terreno ricco,
perché un terreno ricco fa la differenza
su ogni tipo di coltivazione,
e di mostrare al mondo la vostra bellezza
come fanno i fiori per me.
Spero che i fiori siano veramente
qualcosa che nutre la vostra anima
e che voi lo siate per il mondo.
Grazie.
(Applausi)